so what we want to think about is that
what x values does our function here in
orange let me make this clear this is
the graph of y is equal to f of x at
what x values and we have some choices
here which of these x values i should
say does f of x hit relative maximum
values or relative minimum values and i
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it and classify whether we
hit a relative maximum value or relative
minimum value for at each of these x's
so let's first look at x equals a
f of a is right over here this is f of a
and i can pretty easily construct an
open interval around a so that f of x if
x is in this open interval is going to
be is definitely going to be less than
or equal to f of a f of x in that
interval is definitely they're all lower
values than f of a so this right over
here and you can even see it visually
this is kind of the classic
relative
relative
maximum value that we've gotten to
now what about this
so if this was filled in if we were
continuous here this would be pretty
obviously a relative minimum point but
this does something interesting it jumps
up
and so this right over here let's see
this is the value of f of b that is f of
b right over here and this is a little
bit counter-intuitive but i actually can
construct an open interval around b i
can actually construct an open interval
around b where the value of f of x if
it's in that interval is less than or
equal to f of b so f of b right over
here is also is also a relative
maximum value
now what about c right over here well if
this was just at the bottom of a kind of
if it would look like e e is you know
your classic relative minimum point but
see look at this this discontinuity
what's going on here
but we just have to think about well can
we construct an open interval around c
where f of c is this is f of c right
over here where f of c is less than or
equal to the x's in
is less than or equal to f of x for the
x's in that open interval well let's see
in this open interval the way i've drawn
it the f of x's are here
and they are over here so it looks like
f of x is always greater than or equal
to f c so that by that
definition by the the definition of a
relative minimum point this meets it a
relative minimum value so that actually
is a relative minimum value
relative
minimum
now we get over here to d and really by
the same argument that we used for b
that is also
at d our function takes on another
relative maximum point
and then e and when x is equal to e this
is the function hitting well it could
really be considered a classic relative
a classic relative minimum point we can
easily construct an interval where you
take any x in that interval f of x is
going to be greater than or equal to f
of e so this is a relative minimum value
as well